[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy álvaro cordero a escasos
días de la celebración de elecciones
presidenciales en chile este país vive
un rebrote de tensiones con el pueblo
indígena mapuche al sur del país algo
que ha provocado que varias regiones
hayan sido militarizadas por el gobierno
del conservador sebastián piñera un
gesto que ha elevado la atención entre
este pueblo originario del conosur y el
estado chileno hemos decidido decretar
estado de excepción constitucional de
emergencia por grave alteración del
orden público en la provincia de bío bío
y arauco en la región del bío bío y en
la provincia de malleco y cautín en la
región de la araucanía este es un nuevo
capítulo de una conflictiva historia de
décadas de reivindicaciones mapuches que
generalmente han sido desoídas por el
gobierno pero quienes son los mapuches
los mapuches son el pueblo originario
más numeroso de chile y mayoritariamente
viven en las regiones de araucanía y bío
bío aunque también hay una presencia
importante en la patagonia argentina
actualmente tienen presencia total o
parcial en estos territorios pero ellos
reclaman muchos más que les fueron
arrebatados durante los siglos la suya
es una historia de constantes perdidas
desde el siglo 19 hasta la llegada al
poder en 1970 de salvador allende estas
personas fueron marginadas y expulsadas
de sus territorios pero durante el
gobierno del socialista pudieron
comenzar un breve proceso de
recuperación de tierras que finalizó en
1973 con el golpe de estado del
comandante augusto pinochet y la
instauración de la dictadura tras esto
volvió la persecución y la pérdida de
tierras en favor de empresas privadas
que pretendían explotar recursos
naturales la dictadura en chile-
prevaleció por 16 años hasta que fue
depuesto pinochet y en la década de 1990
retomó la democracia
con la transición democrática en chile
vinieron las primeras promesas de
reconocimiento a las minorías indígenas
en el país promesas que nunca llegaron a
materializarse durante el mandato del
conservador patricio aylwin político que
sucedió a pinochet se intentó que los
pueblos indígenas se adhirieran a la
renovación política del país a cambio de
reconocimiento respeto y desarrollo pero
pero no todos los representantes de
estas minorías se quisieron sumar al
desconfiar del oficialismo lo cual
derivó en que a mediados de la década de
1990 comenzaron los primeros
enfrentamientos con la joven democracia
chilena la causa el estado otorgó la
licencia para construir dos represas
hidroeléctricas sobre el río bío bío que
inundaron cientos de hectáreas de
territorio mapuche y obligaron a
desplazar a decenas de familias una
situación que alimentó aún más la
desconfianza hacia los gobernantes que
el promedio que hacen los colores los
huincas los chilenos con las piernas
el miedo que tengo yo por toda la gente
que estoy mandando aquí porque aquí lo
han tropezado mucho con la izquierda los
primeros años de la década de los 2000
fueron los más convulsos bajo el
gobierno del progresista ricardo lagos-
la pre represión policial a las
protestas mapuches aumentó y aparecieron
los primeros fallecidos decenas de
mapuches fueron detenidos y juzgados en
procesos opacos que fueron muy
criticados por naciones unidas y los
abogados de estas comunidades de la
misma matriz que se ha utilizado durante
toda la historia republicana para
perseguir al mundo mapuche la comunidad
mapuche
no es casualidad aquí la ley
anti-terrorista y utiliza el gobierno de
la concertación es la misma ley que
dictó pinochet durante la dictadura este
sentimiento de amenaza generó dentro de
los mapuches la creación de grupos que
se alzaron en armas es así como nació la
coordinadora arauco malleco una
organización que atacó a particulares y
multinacionales que pudieran peligrar la
recuperación de tierras o sobre explotar
los recursos naturales de la zona el
estado chileno no se quedó de brazos
cruzados al contrario los persiguió
durante años bajo la ley de
antiterrorismo usada durante la
dictadura de augusto pinochet los
mapuches que cayeron en prisión
denunciaron numerosas vejaciones tras
las rejas incluso durante el gobierno de
la actual alta comisionada de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos michelle bachelet los mapuches
hechos prisioneros consideraban que no
se les debía aplicar la ley
antiterrorista y la acumulación de
procesos para ampliar sus condenas por
lo que muchos de ellos comenzaron una
huelga de hambre entre el 2010 y el 2011
para ejercer presión contra el primer
gobierno del conservador sebastián
piñera
lo cierto es que independientemente del
color político del gobierno los mapuches
siguieron viendo es atacados por el
estado que nunca abandonó la explotación
de recursos esta situación ha hecho que
su lucha por las tierras se mantenga las
explotaciones mineras y forestales han
dado mucha riqueza a multinacionales
como endesa o codelco pero no han
evitado que la araucanía y bío bío sean
las regiones más pobres de chile desde
2018 con la vuelta al poder por otro
mandato de sebastián piñera los ataques
a camioneros e infraestructuras se
multiplicaron y sus demandas se sumaron
a las de los millones de chilenos que
salieron a las calles a protestar en
octubre de 2019 ahora las esperanzas
están depositadas en la constituyente
sin el era presidida por la activista
mapuche elisa loncón una oportunidad
única para cumplir las reivindicaciones
mapuches y así calmar el conflicto
histórico que se arribó a pocas semanas
de los comicios presidenciales así
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]